ja wir müssen uns die Lage im Osten der
Ukraine angucken dort hat Russland jetzt
eine Art neue Offensive begonnen ein
Versuch sich aus dieser Umklammerung die
ukrainischen gegen offensiven wir wissen
es hier in der Region Raki aber auch im
Süden bei krass sonnen sich daraus zu
lösen und eben selbst wieder die
Offensive zu gewinnen und diese
Offensive bewegt sich etwa in diesem
Raum hier nämlich von afdiefka nördlich
der Großstadt Donalds bis unten nach
Wulle da und dort versucht man
verschiedene ja wir sind auch hier an
einem blauen Farbe in der Vergangenheit
verlorene Gebiete wieder zurück zu
erobern aber eben wir sehen es auch das
Blau ist hier unten sehr sehr wenig das
heißt dort haben die Ukraine im
Gegensatz zu hier oben ist noch gar
nicht geschafft den russischen Vormarsch
aufzuhalten man ist also hier besonders
stark als Russland und versucht hier
weiter vorzudringen und das tut man
unter anderem auch mit seiner Luftwaffe
wir haben hier relativ eindrucksvolle
Aufnahmen aus der Stadt Marinka Marinka
die direkt an der Front liegt der
hintere Teil vielleicht hier am Horizont
das gehört noch den Ukrainern der
vordere Teil den Russen und das Ganze
ist aufgenommen von einer russischen
Drohne und wir schauen uns mal was hier
in die Luft geht nämlich zwei
Kampfflugzeuge können Sie kurz mal
markieren einmal immer da das sind zwei
zu Heu su25 erdkampfflugzeuge und die
Fliegen tatsächlich hier Angriffe über
ukrainischen Gebiet also sie haben keine
Angst vor der ukrainischen Luftabwehr
sondern greifen direkt so wie sie
gedacht sind eben von oben an wir können
uns das nochmal angucken also gerade von
oben an schießen ihre Raketen auf
ukrainische Stellung und drehen dann
wieder ab das ist also schon eine ja
gewisses Selbstbewusstsein was die
Russen jetzt zu haben scheinen eben
direkt die Ukraine von oben anzugreifen
hier scheint die Situation tatsächlich
so schwierig für die Ukrainer zu sein
dass sie eben nicht es geschafft haben
zum Beispiel diese Flugabwehr diese
Schulter gestützten oder auch größere
Flugabwehrgeschütze hier aufzubauen
sondern wir sehen es hier die Russen
können hier direkt ihre Luftwaffe
einsetzen ebenso wie sie gedacht ist die
zu Heu Flugzeuge und die Ukrainer
beschießen ja auch auf dem Boden
versuchen die Russen weiter vorzudringen
und das hier sind wiederum ukrainische
Aufnahmen und wir sehen hier einen
russischen Panzer der versucht
vorzudringen daneben bereits ein
zerstörten russischen Panzer und das
versuchen die Ukraine ihn natürlich so
schwer wie möglich zu machen das heißt
während wir eben gesehen haben dass eben
das die große Luftwaffe relativ einfach
hier operieren kann sind es immer wieder
hier die Russisch die ukrainische
Artillerie die zwischen völlig
zerstörten steht wir können es dazu mal
angucken also jeder dieser dunklen
Flecken hier ist jeweils ein Einschlag
von einer Artillerie das heißt das sind
völlig zerstörte Gegenden zerstörte
Städte die dort weiterhin umkämpft
werden das also russlandsversuche
vorzubringen die eben von der Ukraine
versucht werden zunichte zu machen wie
gesagt hier noch einmal sehen jeder
Punkt ein Atelier Treffer das man kann
also kaum noch normales Sehen und auch
hier rechts wenn man sich das anguckt
das war mal eine Stadt auch da steht
kein einziges Haus mehr was bewohnbar
wäre was versuchen die Hosen zu machen
sie versuchen neuen Nachschub an die
Front zu bekommen und diese Aufnahmen
sind ganz neu aus Russland wir sehen
hier
giazente b-atteriegeschütze das sind
etwa 50 Jahre alte Artilleriegeschütze
die hier an die Front gefahren werden
russland versucht also die relativ
teilweise zumindest modernen Dinge die
sie verloren haben die Waffen diese
verloren haben mit uralte Artillerie
hier wieder zu zu erneuern und auch das
ist hier neu das ist ein ein Zug mit
tankl Fragen und das hier ist ein Ural
sie 375 ein einen Tanklastwagen und der
wird seit 1960 gebaut also auch das
extrem alte Hardware die versucht
Russland jetzt hier an die Front zu
kriegen durch Russland durch Richtung
Ukraine aber wenn wir sagen alt es ist
ganz wichtig dass wir uns klar machen
das heißt nicht dass es ungefährlich
oder weniger tödlich ist noch mal diese
giert sind B ist 152 mm Artillerie die
kann ungefähr 30 Kilometer weit schießen
und hat natürlich eine enorme
Zerstörungskraft wir haben das eben
gesehen das heißt auch wenn Russland
jetzt auf sehr alte nahezu Antike Waffen
zurückgreift ändert das nichts an der
Gefährlichkeit des Landes und an der
Gefährlichkeit der Armee und natürlich
diese Tanklastwagen hier sind sehr sehr
wichtig weil Russland natürlich das
Benzin braucht an der Front um seine
Panzer weiter zu betreiben um die
vorwärts fahren zu können das fällt
ihnen immer schwerer aber die Ukrainer
sehr viel davon zerstört haben deshalb
werden jetzt diese sehr alten und
teilweise auch man sieht das kaputten
LKW die wahrscheinlich 30 40 Jahre nicht
mehr im Einsatz waren genommen um eben
damit die russische Armee wieder in die
Offensive zu kriegen das zumindest der
Wunsch Moskau
[Musik]